I'm going to need
that box that's in the back
We're here to look at a box
that CBP's National Targeting
Center targeted this particular shipment.
The shipper is an entity that's known
to us, they’re a previous offender
for smuggled artifacts
coming into the United States.
We're going to see if there's any more
contraband in this particular shipment
that's coming through
It appears the box contains stone beads.
There are some golden artifacts
on the bottom
but I'm not going to pull it out here
just because we can't afford to lose
any small beads.
We're going to go ahead and transport
this shipment down
to the Diamond District of Manhattan.
And we're going to have a gold specialist
take a look at the gold and determine
exactly what we have
because of the nature, what exactly
the artifact is.
We suspect it might be Bactrian in origin
The Bactrian culture
was an ancient civilization
that partially overlapped
what is now
Present-Day, Afghanistan and Pakistan.
Geographically, situated at the nexus
of a major East-West trade route.
It's a perfect
blending of Greek and southwest Asian art
in 1978 and 79.
Archeologists excavated the tombs of six
wealthy Bactrian
traders
known as the Bactrian Gold.
The collection became a prized part
of Afghanistan's cultural heritage
Then in 2021 following the collapse
of the Afghan government,
the treasure mysteriously went missing
and anti-smuggling authorities
around the world
have been on the lookout for it
ever since.
How many pieces are we testing?
There's a lot of little pieces,
but if you can just do a sampling
that would probably be the way to go.
We do run into a
lot of counterfeit ancient artifacts
that are meant to look ancient.
They're selling them off as ancient,
but they're they're modern made.
So we just want to make sure that
that artifact is the genuine artifact.
All right.
So we're going to start
with this piece. Yep.
This one seems to have like
a semi-precious stone in it.
It looks like part of a Maltese cross
It's interesting.
I mean, this was going back.
You're saying a thousand.
2000 years. Yeah.
This doesn't look like it's real.